bon on va parler de d'hitchcock
maintenant françois truffaut c'est voici
l'édition définitive d'un livre donc sur
hitchcock vous avez publié quelques
années et il faut dire que c'est un
livre qu'il y avait un double but et
vous avez réussi parfaitement puisque
vous vouliez en allant interviewer
hitchcock à hollywood le connaître mieux
parce que c'est elle à nouveau m et
d'autre part vous vouliez imposés in
scope aux états unis qui disaient oh oh
ce n'est pas un très grand metteur en
scène et vous avez réussi les deux
choses il était très célèbre mais ils
n'étaient pas respectées ils n'étaient
pas respectées d'autant moins que il
animait à l'époque une émission de
télévision hebdomadaire de l'histoire de
suspense faire d'abord de 25 minutes qui
à près de 50 minutes qui avait
d'ailleurs un très grand succès et il
apparaissait avant chaque épisode avec
un petit sketch comique très bien écrit
très bien joué mais enfin laisser film
avait un très grand succès c'était
l'époque de l'homme qui en savait trop
de rire windows to catch aussi deux
films qui ont vraiment eu l'ordre ou
souilhe magnifique seulement les
critiques étaient très condescendant
très condescendant
les anglais le mépriser parce qu'ils
étaient aussi jaloux qui dit réussi en
dehors de l'angleterre pour ça les
anglais sont assez dures et puis les
américains étaient condescendant et il
n'y a que les français principalement le
groupe de mes amis d'ailleurs des
cahiers du cinéma le rôle le placions
très haut et nous disions c'est une
américains sont supérieurs à ce film
anglais c'est un homme qui n'a cessé de
faire des progrès et qui a la maîtrise
de son art et voilà on est alors ce
livre a été la continuité de la
continuation de ce travail j'ai
entrepris en 62 après avoir tourné
moi-même de trois filles et lui non lui
fini c'est le film intitulé les oiseaux
bon et puis il est mort hitchcock et là
vous avez donc on fait une nouvelle
édition avec une belle introduction
et puis dans un dernier chapitre bien
vous vous raconter les dernières années
denis chose qui fait que là on a toute
la vie et toute la filmographie de niche
copé alors d'abord il ya des documents
absolument formidable les documents
iconographiques superbe et puis moi je
trouve que cette interview était pas
tant elle est épatante parce que non
seulement on apprend à connaître un
homme qu'on aime beaucoup ici j'aime
beaucoup aimé s'est dit mais je trouve
qu'on comprend très bien ce qu'est le
cinéma ses difficultés ses joies la
difficulté on comprend très bien en
lisant le politique ont mis assez
difficile de construire un film
et puis alors là aussi on voit très bien
les pièges qui lie à la construction
d'un film ensuite on voit bien pourquoi
il était l'image et pas telle autre
c'est très bien expliqué dire que si on
aime le cinéma il faut absolument lire
ce livre parce qu'on comprend pourquoi
rien n'est gratuit le plaisir ce que
vous dites moi j'étais influencé quand
je suis rentré de l'armée il y avait
la télévision n'était pas encore très
importante toute la france écoutez la
radio et on écoutait les entretiens avec
paul léautaud est alors que faisait
robert malley et j'ai acheté le livre d
entretiens et des autos par robert
mallet j'ai dit c'est une forme de
communication formidable entretien
retranscrit imprimés ça m'a énormément
séduit plus tard j'ai même trouvé dans
le commerce quelques disques entretien
les autres robert malley et ça a été un
peu mon modèle c'est dedans on va
prendre son temps mais un magnétophone
et puis on en discute et c'est vrai
qu'avec ce qui est formidable dans son
livre ce que tes questions sont parfois
aussi longue parfois même plus longue
que les réponses de scop donc ce n'est
pas juste le une interview habitués on a
un dialogue
c'est un véritable dialogue entre deux
bons entre un jeune créateur et puis un
maître ça c'était bien
alors moi je pense que je remarque c'est
que bien on parle de la ville hitchcock
et ont d'une certaine manière la vie du
coq c'est le contraire de la vie de
polanski parce que c'est la vie la plus
calme la plus simple
et alors je lui même cette chose vous
dites c'est bush une jolie formule
il est bien évident qu'hitchcock a
organisé toute sa vie en sorte que
l'idée ne vienne à personne de lui
donner une tape dans le dos c'était
c'est le contraire lui de l'acide rohmer
dans ce sens que c'est une vie de
frustration oui je ne pense pas que la
vie de romane cette frustration
hitchcock oui parce qu'ils coke s'est vu
dès le début de la vie comme quelqu'un
en marche quelqu'un qui n'était pas
normalisées vu comme un monstre
physiquement navetteurs be s'est vu
comme un monstre et il s'est mis à avoir
peur à se méfier il avait un
comportement de méfiance à l'égard de
tout le monde et qu'il a en continu est
d'ailleurs entretenir en amérique il
était d'ailleurs très intimidant il ne
faisait rien pour faisait pas grand
chose pour mettre les gens à l'aise sauf
je crois dans les tournages et voilà
donc c'est quelqu'un qui s'est retiré de
la vie volontairement qui en a souffert
mais enfin il a mis à projeter sur les
grands toutes ces émotions qui ne vivrai
jamais qui ne connaîtrait jamais mais
les âges avec une violence forme il
était bien ça roman polanski cet homme
hitchcockien qui s'est marié vierge à 25
ans qui est pas votre cas il n'a jamais
connu une autre femme que la sienne
whissell cet homme a pu représenter le
meurtre et d'adultère comme des
scandales solide savait le faire il sole
il avait le droit de le faire
oui oui mais vous y mènent aux roms
comment pourrait il a fait des chaleurs
oui mais ça change rien
c'est un personnage à la haine ridge mcc
quelqu'un entièrement de frustration je
ne comprends pas la relation entre ce
qu'on fait dans sa vie de la remontée
hier donc il a joué les pauvres en
volume et il a fait des choix des règles
a aussi fait des shader non c'est
simplement c'est que truffaut dit est
que à cause de sa vie parce que il était
frustré il a donc raconter tout ça dans
ses films que peut-être doit-il pas fait
les mêmes films qui n'a pas eu la même
vie oui ça voulait dire c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit aussi que ces scènes
d'amour sont filmés comme des scènes de
meurtre avant la scène de meurtre comme
les scènes d'amour j'avais proposé de la
même chose c'était tout un coin des
versements c'est un déversement qui
arrivent là et qui est très puissant
mais je pense que c'est ça aussi qui
fait que les films sont forts qui sont
bons et qu'ils traversent les années
un film d'hitchcock de 1940 vous allez
le voir aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
l'impression de voir un film de 1940
vous voyez un film qui a une forme très
pur et très serré et qui est s'il était
poignant quand il est sorti il est
encore poignant aujourd'hui c'est ce que
j'aime vous dites qu à la fin de sa vie
il ce coq regrettait le temps des stars
ah parce qu'ils avaient leur féminité il
avait toujours eu besoin de stars parce
que il travaillait sur les situations
plus que sur le personnage il n'avait
pas le temps de construire des
personnages il avait horreur des petites
choses inutiles des petits détails qui
fonderait dans un film donc ils avaient
besoin d'acteurs qui ont déjà une image
qui a même déjà une image alors quand il
avait james stewart par exemple et bien
le personnage était tout de suite
beaucoup plus sympathique parce qu'il
avait fait le film de capra parce qu'il
avait fait ça s'il avait garganta il
avait un séducteur qui arrivait sur
l'écran qui nous avait déjà charmé dans
d'autres films et il a été un peu embêté
justement dans les dernières années de
sa vie surtout quand il a perdu grace
kelly quand il n'a perdu ni guy berryman
tout d'un coup ils n'avaient plus les
acteurs actrices dont ils avaient besoin
et c'était difficile pour lui plus
difficile et il dans une conversation
avec vous il fait une distinction entre
les actrices que marilyn monroe essais
et des actrices comme grace kelly
dick alors expliqué il détestait marine
monroe comme ils étaient testés brigitte
bardot comme il aurait détesté martine
carol il détestait les femmes qui
avaient disait-il le sexe affiché sur la
figure pour lui il fallait une notion de
sexe indirects d'hypocrisie alors pour
lui le comble c'est l anglaise qui n'a
l'air de rien qu'à des lunettes tout ça
et puis qui est capable d'un coup de
déchaînements formidable
voilà c'était ça mais est ce que ce
n'est pas les actrices aussi que préfère
que vous préférez parce que françoise
dorléac catherine deneuve sont plus des
des actrices qui se rapprochent me
semble-t-il de il a pensé travailler
avec l'avionneur
référence moi j'ai un scénar et à mettre
en scène dans laquelle il ya des
personnages tout ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de trouver des interprètes qui
correspond à ses personnages
oui mais il stoppe dit que si on a une
femme qui est très sensuel et bien il
n'y a pas de ya pas de suspense au fond
c'est très bien ce qui va se passer
parce que si on a une femme peut éthérée
un peu froide assez blonde ça dépend
uniquement de l'histoire que vous que
vous racontez et quel est votre avis à
vous et en scène franco roumaine travail
plus comme fellini c'est à dire ils
aiment qu'un personnage ressemble à un
dessin presque un dessin humoristique ou
par exemple à un animal ou à moi je fais
ça c'est ça il faut des dessins truc
l'est beaucoup plus proche de fellini
dans ce sens mais vous vous risquez de
lui chercher des presque des gravures de
mode pour ce truc au metteur en scène
oui qu'elle en fait la distinction celle
de sorte de pas à je vois bien ce que je
voulais dire mais enfin moi je suis
assez en faveur
c'est pour ça que j'aime tellement au
noir je suis assez en faveur du film de
personnages c'est à dire quand le
personnage est très vivant on a besoin
de peu d'histoire ou de mois d'action et
j'aime assez les films de personnages ou
les personnages sont importants est-ce
que vous reconnaissez survol influence
d'hiscox n'ont pas vraiment à peut-être
dans certains dans certains instants les
rarement parce que truffaut dit que
notamment le psycho berthillot vertigo
ont exercé une grande influence au bruit
metteur en scène et ils vous cite et il
vous suit à propos de répulsion je vous
dirais que oui
en effet dans cette instance particulier
je dirais que psychose m'influencer un
peu a certainement mais pardon sais pas
si c'était comédiens pour la musique
aussi pour la musique c'est possible le
tire lait truction mais tout ça c'est
possible en tout cas vous savez c'est un
film répulsion un film comme qui n'était
pas vraiment eu exactement ce que
j'avais envie de faire à ce moment je le
fais parce qu'il fallait travailler
fallait faire un film comme ça et ce qui
me plaisait plaisait le plus dense dans
le genre c'était bien sûr psychose
et puis ce qui est très intéressant
c'est la manière dont ils scott explique
la différence entre ce que dit qu'une
image est ce que disent les acteurs et
souvent ça n'est pas la même chose et
même dit il
le bon cinéma le grand cinéma c'est
lorsque il y a il y a les divorces entre
les étalages
oui oui c'est ça le décalage c'est à
dire qu'il était très fort là dessus
pour que la caméra soit par exemple sur
la personne qui écoute et non pas sur
celle qui parle et à ce moment là ça
devient un deuxième sens le sens devient
l'émotion de la personne qui écoute et
ce qui fait que la personne qui parle
elle peut mentir à ce moment là oui
c'est ça ça par exemple où le fait très
bien à vos plumes dans le dernier métro
l'a souvent il ya des scènes où les gens
disent des paroles et en vérité ils
pensent à autre chose ils disent autre
chose par leurs yeux par leur bouche par
à leur attitude je cache pas je suis
très enfin quand j'ai des difficultés
souvent comment est ce qu'on a fait et
peut-être ça met souvent à trouver oui
mais comment était-il avec vous jusqu'à
que est-ce que c'était un personnage
renfermé parce que si c'est bizarre
parce qu'on me dit frustré en même temps
au comptant à l'image de l'huile un type
mais boire que mais les bonnes
bouteilles françaises qui aimait et qui
était drôle et c'est qu'ils aient des
plaisanteries
ah oui oui oui jusque deux dernières
années de sa vie il était assez drôle
d'idée mais blagué
les noms il était très jovial et c'est
chaleureux
il a un goût très juste parce que bruit
raconter comment vous êtes arrivé avec
chabrol pour nous c'est une scène
absolument que ça lui a permis à ben
c'est à dire que la wii nous ne l'avions
jamais vu à ce moment là c'était
vraiment la première visite et on sait
qu'il est en train de faire du doublage
au studio de joinville donc qui nous
attend là dans le studio de doublage
alors on entend sur doublage il fait
tout noir et sur l'écran il ya gary
grant et brigitte auber sur un petit
bateau avec des paroles vont donc ils
font du doublage et il nous dit ah oui
c'est vous les journalistes de cahiers
du cinéma bon allait m'attendre au bar
du studio et le bar de studio était de
l'autre côté
l'auditorium et et c'était l'hiver et le
bitume est aigri et puis il y avait un
petit rebord un moment mais on pense que
tu es un rebord qui faisait partie de
bitume et on est en jambes sur bord et
on se trouve dans un bassin gelé la
glace qui casse d'un seul coup truffaut
et chabrol ou et le bassin et est
incurvé on se retrouvera avec de l'eau
jusqu'à la poitrine et jeudi à chabrol
mais qu'est ce qui se passe avec le
magnétophone alors il ne sort le
dégouliner magnétophone à l'époque était
très lourd et pas les mimiques à 7
et puis il ya une femme qui nous voilà
on tournait dans son studio rififi chez
les hommes alors il ya une femme qui
nous prend pour des figurants de rififi
chez les hommes elle nous disait des
figurants population venez vous séchez
nous amène dans une loge et on lui dit
on ne joue pas dans rififi chez les
hommes alors là bas on peut rien faire
pour vous alors après une scop nous un
peu plus tard et très compatissant parce
qu'on était encore d'oublier
ils nous donnent rendez vous pour le
soir à son hôtel et puis ça a créé des
liens évidemment cette première cette
façon de se rencontrer parce que l'année
suivante on le revoit encore à paris à
cette époque là il avait l'habitude il
venait une fois par an à paris pour
promouvoir son film est alors il nous a
dit à chabrol et moi et je pense à vous
chaque fois que je vois des glaçons dans
un verre de whisky et après plus tard à
los angeles j'ai appris qu'il avait
raconté l'histoire à sa femme à ses
collaborateurs au studio mais il s'était
amusé à améliorer encore l'histoire
alors il disait dans son histoire
racontée par lui que effectivement nous
avait pris pour des figurants après la
chute dans l'eau et que quand on était
revenu me voir
chabrol sérieux
curé mois en flic ça montre aussi son
sens toujours martine aubry